y en más de una ocasión hemos escuchado
pronunciado la palabra estar y en estos
últimos meses y años hemos visto algunas
noticias sobre ellas pero qué significa
un estado esta forma de negocio que
desde hace ya un par de años está en la
boca de todos y se ha convertido en la
vía rápida para un buen emprendimiento
además se han expandido a todo tipo de
sectores y países por eso hoy vamos a
hablar de ellas y claro que nos acompaña
también nuestro cronista económico luis
méndez louis bienvenido a esta segunda
entrevista del día también a esta mesa
de trabajo nuevamente muchas gracias
raúl bueno es un término que empezó
básicamente a moldearse desde 1950
cuando se estableció silicon valley en
california para recibir algunas empresas
que ya empezaban a desarrollar
tecnología pero se acuñó aún más a lo
que es hoy en día lo que conocemos hoy
en día en
1980 ya cuando empiezan a surgir una
serie de nuevos emprendimientos
orientados hacia el servicio al cliente
basados en elementos tecnológicos en
este caso y por ello es que hoy es tan
importante este tema porque para muchos
especialistas en la base de lo que puede
ser un gran sueño para cualquier persona
así es y vamos a hablar entonces con uno
de los fundadores de una de estas start
vélez daniel bilbao campo co founder
visión de la empresa true ahora danielle
gracias por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de france 24 feliz
mañana de jueves para ti quiero
preguntarle quiero preguntarle entonces
qué se necesita para que una de las
startups más grandes o más importantes
de américa latina logre por ejemplo 15
millones de dólares como los que ya
levantó su empresa tú ahora no y además
donde buscan en los inversionistas o
ustedes cómo estará este dinero
bueno primero que nada muchas gracias
por la invitación y pues empecemos con
las bases con un start es un grupo de
personas que se conecta con un capital
en para tratar de solucionar un problema
o sea se imaginan un futuro en el cual
hay un problema que ya no existe y
trabajan para solucionar ese problema
entonces ese es el cuerpo ahora como
hace un startup
latino para levantar capital pues tiene
que buscar varios elementos en etapa
temprana que es la que estamos nosotros
de presidir y si vice o sea de sería que
son como los pasos que se requieren para
hacer un emprendimiento y lo más
importante es el equipo y el equipo que
está solucionando un problema real un
problema que es es importante y el
tercer punto si buscamos sólo tres
extracción es mostrar a partir del
crecimiento de ese negocio de las ventas
que están haciendo el servicio que están
prestando en la que sea que es la
métrica importante de llegar a un nivel
donde los inversionistas dicen aquí hay
algo esta empresa puede tener puede ser
transformacional y solucionar este
problema
y por eso decidimos darle capital para
que crezca a toda velocidad y llegue a
solucionar ese problema también en el
caso de tú ahora como iniciaron ustedes
este acercamiento para recibir la
inversión a través de un fondo se
acercaron directamente inversores
individuales
y nosotros empezamos en 2018 y nuestra
historia es un poco inusual lo que
hicimos fue que queríamos que nosotros
creemos que el talento es distribuye
equitativamente y las oportunidades no y
entonces contratamos 8 ingenieros
estudiantes en cali en colombia donde
soy yo y empezamos a desarrollar
software ahí y cuando empezamos a
fondear nos hablamos con inversionistas
ángeles fundadores que habían hecho
stars y algunos fondos aquí tengo uno
enfrente mío que se llama magma que
necesitan las té que nos ayudan mucho y
levantamos 200.000 dólares de fondos
pequeños y ángeles inversionistas esa
fue la primera parte
danielle también le quiero preguntar de
este porcentaje de estados cuales se
mantienen hoy en el tiempo y según usted
cuál es el secreto para lograrlo digamos
que este emprendimiento se mantenga y a
lo mejor llega a ser un unicornio una
gran empresa ya constituida no
es un tema difícil por estos días antes
de 2019 era algo así como que hay un
número de estados que llegan han sido o
sea semilla como un tercio son sería un
tercio en serio y con la mitad es en
serie c entonces para existir uno tiene
un chance de 191 en 18 en porque tuvimos
lo que yo solo puedo escribir como una
burbuja económica en la época de cobb en
todo el mundo y su mamá está adelantando
rondas y creciendo entonces ahora
nosotros tenemos muchos unicornios que
francamente no valen lo que la
valoración de tierra entonces lo que
vamos a ver en los próximos dos años que
son regresos como valoraciones
fundamentales y en números fundamentales
en para para sobrevivir o para existir
un startup tiene que
demostrar que es una buena inversión
además de solucionar un problema
entonces uno tiene que tener buenos y
unir económicos o sea que el
revenue que hace por transacción es
positivo tiene que tener un crecimiento
considerable de por lo menos dos veces o
sea de ser el doble de grande cada año y
hacerlo sin tener un la quema de plata o
programa como le llamamos nosotros
exagerada porque el mercado ahorita con
la corrección que está pasando en el
mercado capital no no aprueba que uno
queme y que me queme y crezca a toda
costa ahorita hay que crecer de manera
eficiente danielle y a qué se debe el
fenómeno de ese número de startups que
están creciendo en latinoamérica y
muchas de ellas se están llegando a
transformar en unicornio en el año 2021
18 de ellas llegaron a consolidarse en
unicornios es son dos razones el primero
es que latinoamérica siempre estuvo
android playstation o invertíamos lo
suficiente tenemos una cosa o sea
teníamos un como era era como un 25 a
unos 50 dólares de la inversión de india
entonces cuando llegó software y mostró
que había inversión de gross o sea en la
última etapa pues hubo mucho más interés
en la región vinieron mucho más fondos
americanos y otras partes y se dieron
cuenta que la calidad de emprendedores y
de equipos era alta llaman latinoamérica
desafortunadamente está lleno de
problemas entonces un mercado lleno de
problemas con buenos emprendedores lo
único que faltaba era el capital y a
medida que se despliega ese capital pues
empiezan a crecer las compañías
y son compañías más grandes usualmente
que las americanas porque por ejemplo en
eeuu uno puede solucionar un problema
pequeño específico de una industria
llegar a 100 millones de dólares en
latinoamérica te toca solucionar todo el
problema porque a pesar de que el
mercado es más pequeño todo esos
pedacitos no existen en todas las
empresas latinoamericanas tienden a ser
más grandes y más transformacional es
para la industria que las americanas
están han sido las razones principales
de desde el día de hoy daniel de aquí a
10 años como ve este fenómeno de estar o
puede crecer se puede estancar puede
disminuir como lo ve el próximo partido
en pasar duro o sea ustedes van a ver
mucho mucho
estaba sufriendo sobre todos los de
gross pero en diez años
si usted no hace un ranking de las 50
empresas 100 empresas más grandes de
latinoamérica el 70 80 por ciento van a
ser stars y el 70 80 por ciento van a
ser empresas de tecnología agarré la
lista la que sea y miren quiénes son los
más grandes y les garantizo que ha
puesto un año de vida lo que quieran a
que el 70 80 por ciento de la de strauss
digo de las compañías más valiosas de
latinoamérica van a ser de base
tecnológica y van a haber sido estar en
esta época o de pronto ni siquiera han
nacido también y respecto a ese
comentario que acs cómo evaluar entonces
ese proceso de diversificación que están
dando las startups a nivel de
latinoamérica vemos que cada vez son más
las que se están sumando a sectores de
salud por ejemplo otros al servicio de
transporte como como podría ser entonces
a largo plazo ese proceso
como yo pienso es evoluciones
cómo te explico eso alguien está
buscando trabajo dice en que va a
trabajar y se va a trabajar en finanzas
no es como hacía en finanzas en bolsa en
banca en otros finanza es como un caso
de un término todo general nosotros
ahorita llamamos una startup tecnológica
cualquier cosa que tiene tec entonces
uno puede meterse en salud uno se puede
meter en transporte se puede meter en
educación y se siente como un start up
the tech lo que va a pasar es que el
software y la tecnología va a ser tan
abundante en todas las industrias que
vamos a pasar de decir eso es una
empresa de tec a esa es una empresa de
salud puedes hacer una empresa de
seguros o es una empresa de banca y
vamos a dejar de decir tec como algo
necesario así como no asumimos que hay
un departamento de finanzas en todas las
industrias sexy me explico
y lo que está pasando ahorita es que los
problemas más grandes que tienen más
como
jugadores ensanchados como el de salud
donde participa mucho el gobierno o como
los de infraestructura es más difícil
que entren los stavros pero ya que se va
viendo que este es un modelo que
funciona muy bien vamos a ver cada vez
más en construcción en infraestructura
en salud en energía en lo que llamamos
nosotros hard tech o tecnología difícil
no sólo software y eso está pasando cada
vez más en latinoamérica no a la rata
que podría pero pero cada vez está
pasando más danielle hablando de
latinoamérica nuevamente cuáles son esos
países que más estar obtienen digamos
los promotores donde mejor les va y por
qué
y mira que es irónico brasil tiene el
ecosistema más desarrollado de latam
méxico está bastante bien colombia
bastante bien pero está bien quedado
argentina tiene muy buen talento de
startups y no tantas estados pero tiene
muy buen talento y el ecosistema es más
maduro porque tuvieron unos grandes
campeones en su momento y fueron mercado
libre y despegar en cada cada país
empieza teniendo sus grandes campeones y
eso afecta en la economía en colombia'
rápido gracias rápida es 60
emprendedores nuevos y hay un grupo
completo de exalumnos que está
emprendiendo
entonces ese efecto como el gran campeón
es el que hace diferencia es parecido a
cuando fernando alonso ganó en la
fórmula 1 o cuando un futbolista
de latinoamérica llega al real madrid
como cuando a media contra el madrid
todo el mundo quiere jugar fútbol o en
iron estado en el tour de francia
entonces tienen como ese esa visión de
podemos llegar allá eso lo que está
pasando en los startups y apenas tenemos
una grande muy muy muy muy grande vienen
todas las demás de atrás
la clave el éxito a lo mejor daniel se
puede resumir de lo que me quedo en la
conversación usted ya me dirá en la
innovación el trabajo de equipo y
también la transformación esa sería la
clave del éxito para un estado vi que le
diría a los emprendedores que nos están
viendo en este momento que se animen a
pues crear su empresa y obviamente un
fácil pero también cómo hacer para para
lograr el éxito en este negocio le
agregué un punto la resiliencia
instaura es tiene es como una montaña
rusa tiene momentos de su vida tiene
momentos de bajada y la gente que que es
genuinamente exitosa tiene mucha suerte
pero sobrevive entonces mi recomendación
es pues la vida se acaba la gente se
muere si no va a dedicar la vida a algo
pues que sea una cosa de impacto
entonces por eso es mejor trabajar en
esta hora porque no invitó a todas las
personas que lo están considerando que
lo hagan no no es fácil pero muchas más
personas pueden hacer un emprendimiento
de las que creen hay todo tipo